the sheer scale of the refugee crisis in
Bangladesh hundreds of thousands ver
Hingham Muslims are living in squalid
camps just like this they've fled
Myanmar because of army led violence
following a military crackdown but with
agreement from Myanmar Bangladesh is
beginning the enormous task of trying to
repatriate them and it's a move that is
proving deeply unpopular
there hing a community leader told me
that my number has been listed and I
have to return to Myanmar but my son and
daughter were killed there I cannot pray
there no one talks about our rights
there we were sent away after being
labeled as Bengali we will not go back
there this family fled the Bangladeshi
camp they called their home and they're
in hiding they're fearful of returning
to Myanmar they have tortured us so much
there are no words to explain it we went
through so much pain and if we go back
again to face the same why should we go
it's better to die here by taking poison
there we'll have to stay in camps we're
already in camps here I feel that I will
die here so don't try to send us there
eight organizations and the UN refugee
agency admit there are still concerns
for the safety of those who do return
but nevertheless the work to repatriate
150 row hanga each day is underway we're
still talking to the ringa refugees our
people are working on the ground to
encourage them to go back our associated
organizations are also working life in
the camps is far from easy
but for many were hinga staying here
still seems better than being forced to
return back home